casual relationships leave women unhappy  in the long term if they don't have a  family yeah but that also depends on the  mentality of the people around them the  men at the time so a woman you can  consider quite Pious now you could go  back 10 years and she's now someone  who's acting completely wildling out oh  yeah part of it is like the the birth  Society birth control change dating  forever yeah like that in a way you  can't go back absolutely but yeah I  personally I don't think casual sex is  is the worst thing it has to be  approached with care it's not something  you do carelessly this idea that yeah  just sleep around it's like whoever you  want whatever is is the reason that a  lot of these girls out here getting  played and Crossing two things casual  and intimate and they don't even know  but I know